another indictment you've heard about
this a former president Donald Trump
this one for his alleged mishandling of
classified documents his lawyer told CNN
he faces multiple felony charges
including a violation of the Espionage
Act along with obstruction of justice
conspiracy and making false statements
now in a surprising move Trump was first
to reveal the indictment on his social
media account it follows a months-long
investigation by a special counsel and
it is the first time that a former
president has ever faced federal charges
Trump also faces 34 state-level felony
charges in a separate issue and other
investigations are still going on